it's insane I've actually never been to
a comic-con before in my life and I'm
also a little bit jet-lagged so it's a
bit whoa a little bit loopy and of
course I mean you're part of one of the
biggest film franchises on the planet
how does it feel to be part of that can
you tell us how you've got casco
involved well I was like a massive fan
of the books before any of this happened
and I think it was kind of a good thing
that I didn't quite realize how big it
was I sort of just focused on the
character and when I read the books I
remember falling in love with Annie so
much just feeling so connected to it and
then it sort of was one of those
audition experiences where everything
just fell into place it was almost like
nervous kind of meant to be or something
thank you approach acting your own
having made that work seen a new
prophecy of a vision that character
region is like how's that influenced you
well I think first of all I guess you
kind of bring yourself to the role a
little bit like I think physically it
kind of like worked for me a little bit
and then sort of Annie has this really
amazing emotional life she sort of been
through so much as have all of them but
I guess I I kind of like everyone's been
through really intense stuff and I I
just kind of tapped into that little
well of pain that everyone has to just
kind of really go there for Annie I mean
obviously Annie was introduced in
Catching Fire but for fans who maybe
haven't read the books and they're kind
of just waiting for Mockingjay as a film
you tell us a little bit about just
where Annie fits into the world of
hunger games and and significance as
things go on to me is a little bit like
sort of the appearing of hope in a
little in a way because she's been
through hell and back and yet she sort
of her love for Finnick and their love
for each other is something that helps
them to survive because the real battle
even though she doesn't have any
physical scars there's a lot of
emotional scars so it's that love that
kind of um it's it's all survivalism in
some way so she manages to survive her
in mind
because of Vinick and so that's kind of
like a running through line for the film
I guess all the characters are surviving
so much and it's different things keep
them going and for Annie it's love it's
a great relationship between a hammy and
thinit can you talk about working with
Sam obviously a wonderful act awesome we
had so much fun together I think we're
very similar we actually sort of play
around a lot and stuff like that we're
both theatre kids so we had a lot of fun
in times where we weren't doing things
we'd like pretend to like slap each
other and all the extras oh my god so it
was really it was a ball and he's he's
such a great actor like he's got such a
beautiful emotional life as a performer
and he's just a sweetheart
so it was just it was I had the best
time working with him I mean this is
clearly one of the best casts we've seen
particular summer blockbuster kind of
franchise like this for quite some time
you talked a little bit about working
with the rest of the cast means taking
people like Jennifer I mean a wonderful
time well it's just like it's incredible
I have so much respect for them as as
artists and as people as well like
they're just they're incredible artists
I feel so blessed to be amongst them but
also they're just the sweetest most
grounded people I've had the pleasure of
working with like they're just it's not
a bad bone in their body they're just so
fun loving and it is like a big family
and I felt like I was just adopted into
it pretty quickly and just watching them
work and then also just getting to hang
out with them was just really cool you
have any favorite memories from from
certain experiences that just make you
crack a big smile every time you think
about them now yeah plenty plenty of the
trickery that went on there was a lot of
it's a very playful set you kind of got
to watch your back a little bit so there
were a few things that went on my first
day completely thrown into it so it was
just very cool of course I mean we've
had our trailers for Mockingjay part 1
Catching Fire really expanded the world
of The Hunger Games and kind of set up
this big finale what can fans expect
overall particular from this first part
Mockingjay well without giving it away
gets more and more intense so I don't
want to say too much but it it's just it
is
a very intense story but there's moments
of just absolute beauty as well but it's
such a heartbreaking the story but at
the same time it it's one of hope as
well I guess for Humanity so and it's
gonna be epic so I can't wait to see how
it how it turns out I mean talking about
heartbreaking
obviously Philip Seymour Hoffman one of
the finest actors of his generation and
this is going to be one of his final
performances can you talk a little bit
about what made him such an
extraordinary challenge in their talent
and your memories of Philip well I I
felt really really blessed to have met
him a couple of times just before and he
he was such a beautiful beautiful man
and he was just completely had some
really great conversations with him and
I think I've have really good memories
of talking to him about the theater he
had such a love for theater and we
shared a love of the Sydney Theatre
Company back home and things like that
and I mean he's special
he's absolutely special in the world is
not going to be the same without him
he's the way he just completely
transforms with his characters and yeah
he's it was yeah there's no words think
you can't replace someone like that
there's a fan of the book some what have
you most enjoyed about bringing your
parent just life and what particular
things you enjoying bringing for life on
the screen from the book thank you oh
god that's like picking between you kids
like there's so many so many good ones
but I think it's really it's really such
a cool thing to play that like
unconditional love like that's such a
nice thing like there's no there's no
sort of like maybes in that relationship
it's just pure kind of you would do
anything for that person and that's like
a really fun thing to play because
that's rare in life and it's what
everyone kind of hopes for and then
playing these two characters that would
die for each other it's just kind of fun
I guess what you can tell us about is
working with your director and Francis I
mean obviously fans a great force behind
the camera oh my god he is
it was a dream waking with him he was
he's such a collaborative director and
he's also just so sweet and so funny and
got involved with all the the games and
the trickery but he's he was just it was
effortless working with him he was just
so incredible and he's got such an
amazing vision for these films and he's
going to do it spectacular job with it
I'm gonna be super exciting to see what
he does with it you've mentioned this
trickery and games thing that's going on
behind the scenes
so are you guys are having your own type
of like actors directors like Hunger
Games thing going on in the background
as well yeah there's I don't know if
people know about this the game thing
that goes on the this game does anyone
know about that game oh it's like I
would explain it cuz I was new to it
where you do that and then you have to
like shove your finger in the hole and
then catch it and if you don't make it
in time you get punch and then if you do
make it you get to punch someone else
twice I think it is don't quote me on
that
but it went on a lot and it was awesome
to watch to be punched and to punch I
wish I would have if I was there longer
I would have become an absolute master
at it but a lot of them really really
well Jenna has it down oh yeah I'm
pretty sure she brought it into the I
don't know if it was Josh or Jen but one
of them did you're gonna be taking it
the futures that's definitely I just get
better at it yeah I mean you mentioned
him there obviously I'm which is widely
accepted as one of the greatest
actresses of a generation what do you
think separates from kind of you know
all the other kind of you know very
promising young stars that we see at the
moment she has this amazing truthfulness
behind her work and also you know huge
depth and she's a sort of actress that
can go to really deep places really
quickly and then turn it off and be
completely like joking around then go
back to again it was kind of really cool
to watch and she's also just a really
beautiful person and really funny but
yes she she definitely
she definitely has this her craft is
brilliant
so she's yeah she's special what kind of
mental preparations do you have to do
while attacking this well I think with a
role like this it's kind of that that
sort of willingness to be vulnerable
that's sometimes hard because as people
we spend our whole lives putting walls
up and then with a role like this you've
kind of got to smash it back back down
again so it's kind of that thing of
letting go I suppose and then just
really getting inside the world of which
they live so reading the books and just
going over that and software that was
really important to me to be accurate to
it have you got a message for that
before you leave us it you're amazing I
love you we'd be nowhere without you say
thank you
you